Let's try cross-tabing in Alteryx.
But before we do this,
let's count the schools by zip code and
level description to see what that
would look like in the summarize tool.
When we look at the result,
we can see that the data
is showing counts of schools by
zip code and by level description.
But what we're trying to achieve is
to create new fields out of the level
description values that count
the number of schools in each
of those categories by zip code.
To do this,
we'll use the cross-tab tool.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
After attaching the cross-tab tool,
we'll set it up.
The group data by these
values represents what we
want to see at the record level.
In this case, it's zip codes.
The new column headers represents
the fields that will be
created from the values
in that column of data.
So if we want to see one field for
each level description,
then we select LevelDesk here.
Next, in the values for new columns,
we need to select a numeric field so
account can be generated for
each of the records.
We'll select Enrollment.
In the method for aggregating values,
we'll select Count [without Nulls],
which counts the number of
records without null values.
The end result have the level
descriptions listed across the top and
the zip codes along the side, along with
the individual counts of schools that
fall in each of these categories.
We can easily remove the count
prefix in the Select tool.
We select the fields that we
want to remove the prefix for.
Go to Options &gt; Remove Prefix, and
select Remove "Count_".
When we run the workflow, [SOUND],
we can see that that word count
has been removed from the fields.
[BLANK_AUDIO]